SPEAKER: Cloud Spanner is
unique in the marketplace
because it combines
both relational database
structure with horizontal
scale and performance.
What this means is
that this significantly
simplifies application
development and database
management, allowing you to
deliver your apps faster.
For example, for globally
distributed apps,
Cloud Spanner's
multi-regional configuration
automatically replicates a
database across continents,
allowing for localized
reads, minimizing latency.
Creating or scaling such a
globally replicated database
only takes a handful of
clicks on the console.
At Google, we use Cloud
Spanner for our own mission
critical services and apps
that billions of people
across the world
access every day,
so downtime just
isn't an option.
This hands-on lab shows you
how to create a Cloud Spanner
instance, database, and
table, add a schema,
write and modify
data, and run a query.
Cloud Spanner is ideal for
relational, structured,
and semi-structured
data that requires
high availability, strong
consistency, and transactional
reads and writes.
Next up on our quest is
the Internet of Things--
Qwik Start.